Hello, this is Jin. Today we are looking
at our third commander precon scions and
spellcraft. And again, we are going to
look at this deck, go through the cards,
and yeah, see which cards to cut, which
cards to add to make this a bracket
three potentially. All right, let's go.
And this is supposed to be the most
popular commander.
Okay, so here is again the deck box. Not
super useful because I mean it's fine.
It's kind of flimsy, but aside from
that, we have the deck and a pack.
Oh, here you go.
We'll leave this here. So, let's take a
look at Yish. What's her name? Yes. Yes.
Yes.
Um,
all right.
Start with the commander.
So, first of all, it's a four mana two
for with vigilance. At the beginning of
each end step, if a player lost four or
more life this turn, you draw a card
already. Really good. And whenever you
cast a non-creature spell with mana
value three or greater, your
deals two damage to each opponent and
you gain two life H.
Yeah. So basically, you want to cast two
spells a turn ideally or spells that
drain your opponents. So then yeah, this
seems seems pretty strong. I can see why
she's popular because it's very
open-ended. You can play all kinds of
strategies. You can play aggro even. Uh
yeah, so but I'm expecting this to be a
spellinger deck. Graatia. This one we
actually built uh a few days ago from a
collector's box, but this one is like a
shark typhoon kind of effect. Whenever
you cast a spell, you make an XX and
it's a hero. Yeah, it's a hero with X
counters on it. So, it's actually bigger
than XX, but it's only once a turn and
you have to pay life and archander gains
life. So, this is pretty good synergy.
I'd say they work well with each other.
Nice. Next up,
Astral Astrologians. Astrologians Planet
Sphere. two mana job select equipped
creature is a wizard and whenever you
cast a non creature spell and whenever
you draw your third card each turn put a
plus one plus one counter on this
creature.
Uh I don't think are we a speller deck?
We'll have to see but for now the first
card being this makes me a little bit
confused because are we are we playing
equipments? Are we going to attack with
our commander? That doesn't seem super
efficient.
And we just have a creature that gets
bigger for each non-creature spell we
cast. So based on what our commander
says, I'm guessing plus one plus maybe
plus two per turn.
And that's not that big. So I'll put
this in maybe. But it's a very tentative
maybe because we'll see what the deck
does first. Next up, Alice Level partner
with Alford. Elf node leveler.
Uh, first strike. The second spell you
cast each turn costs two less to cast.
Yeah. So, this makes sense because you
want two spells a turn with Yota to
trigger that four damage or the four uh
four life loss trigger.
Um, it's got partner. So, we'll have to
see the partner to evaluate. Uh, let's
find the partner.
There you go. Alphaold,
but on her own this ability or on his
own, I'm not sure. Uh, the ability is
not too powerful. Let's see. Alphod.
Whenever you cast your second spell each
turn, draw a card for four mana. Yeah,
these effects are not too powerful, I'd
say. Like, would you play these?
It's difficult to evaluate partners
because I guess you can evaluate them
like room spells, right? Except you
don't get to choose which side first.
You You get this and then you get the
other side. But I think it's close
enough. Would I play these? Would I play
this if this was a room card?
I think yes. I think I'd say yes. So,
yeah. Again, these fit the theme of the
deck that I suspect the deck to be.
Non-creature spells. Okay. When this
enchantment enters, create X11 colorless
hero creature tokens. When you attack
with four or more creatures, Sky two,
then draw a card. Are we a token deck? I
mean, I know this triggers our
commander, but
I mean, we do have one token maker. We
do have one token maker, but we'll see.
If we have more tokens, then this will
stay in. It seems like we have a bit of
a token sub theme, so we'll put this in
the deck for now. Uh, okay. Next up,
dancers checks. Check rams.
Uh, four mana equipment. It says equip
creature gets plus2 plus two and
lifelink
and other commanders you control get
plus2 plus two and have lifelink and is
a performer equip three.
So six cards in I'm already really
confused. I understand the lifelink
works well with our commander here.
Yeah, because
with this equipped onto our commander or
with this equipped onto any creature
actually, we get to deal two damage to
each opponent, but gain eight life if
there are three opponents. So, there's
some synergy, but that alone I don't
think is good enough. It's just kind of
a decent equipment to have. So, we have
kind of Okay, we have Spellinger, we've
got tokens, and we've got Well, let's
put our commander here. Whoops.
Yeah, spell slinger, we've got tokens,
and we've got equipments.
And so far, I see I see some synergy
between the the piles, but not too much.
Next, what? Next up, the good king Mog
12 summon. Create 212 white Mughal
creature tokens with lifelink. Whenever
you cast a non-creature spell, create a
token that is copy of a non saga token
you control and then you can put two
counters on each mug. So you can kind of
do a mini overrun with these lifelinking
muggles. Yeah. So this is a spell
slinger payoff. Also makes tokens. Okay.
So so far I see spells slinger. I see
tokens. Um next up, Tataru. Taru. When
Tataru Taro enters, you draw a card and
target opponent may draw a card.
Whenever an opponent draws a card, if it
isn't that player's turn, create a
tapped treasure token. This ability
triggers only once each turn. H.
This is a great value. You draw a card
and you also get a treasure guaranteed.
But this ability isn't going to trigger
too much because
your opponents have to draw not only
extra on on their turn, but it's not
like the cards where they trigger on
when your opponents draw two cards on
their turn. That those are actually
easier. Your opponent has to draw cards
on other people's turn, which requires
very specific opponents. So, I don't
think this fits into any of our themes.
So, I I'll make an extra maybe pile, I
guess, for now. is for now. I'm not even
sure if any of these are being cut or
all these.
Fenrit Waters, it's got five out of
three five flash. When they enter
another target legendary permanent you
control against indestructible for as
long as you control Fredrit waters
whenever you cast non creature spell,
this gains indestructible until the end
of turn. It's decent because our deck is
most likely operating at instant speed.
I hope. If it is, then this is a nice
protection spell for any well, it has to
be for our commander because legendary
permanent. And also then we untap and we
can hold up a spell to protect this and
our commander.
Our commander should be fairly
important, fairly key to our game plan
because in spellinger is hard to find
win conditions. So I will put this in
for now. This I would count this towards
spellinger even though it's a creature
because again it triggers off
non-creature spells. Next up, blue
mage's cane. Another equipment.
Equipped creature gets plus O plus two
is a wizard in addition to his other
types and has whenever this creature
attacks. Exile up to one target instant
or sorcery from defending players
graveyard. If you do copy it, you can
cast the copy by paying three rather
than paying it mana cost.
Um,
it does sling spells. It's a little bit
expensive. You have to pay three, then
two, then three again to get one spell.
But once it's equipped, if you can keep
it around, it can generate lots of value
and the spells can trigger our
commander. So even though this is an
equipment, I can see it being decent.
Unlike these that don't do enough, I
think this can do okay in a spell
slinger deck depending on what your
opponents have. And you're copying their
large large speller, so you can trigger
the show. So I'll keep this in for now
because for some reason I I feel like we
might be cutting a lot of cards here. I
hope not, but just got a feeling.
Hermes, overseer of Alis. Alpus.
Whenever you cast a non-creature spell,
good. There's the synergy we're looking
for. Create a one- one blue bird
creature token with flying and
vigilance. Whenever you attack with one
or more birds, scry too.
See, it could have been one or more
tokens to kind of unite our theme, but
it has to be birds. I guess it's
thematic to the character. But this is
not a very powerful effect. I think it
barely makes it. I mean, compared this
to the other spellinger token makers, I
think this falls short. Yeah, we'd
rather have two twos or xx rather than
just one ones. Like scry 2 is kind of
marginal. Yeah, this card barely makes
it. I hope the other spell singing
payoff can be stronger than this.
Oh boy, this this is cool.
Of the first blood, I think I nailed it.
Hardware of the first blood. Oh, it's a
outer dragon. Holy Flying Vigilance W
two. When Hardware enters and whenever
you cast a non-creature spell, target
creature gets plus one plus and can't be
blocked this turn.
I mean, that is not a good payoff for
Spellinger.
It's like they're trying to force
Spellinger so they give this ability
that reads like it has synergy, but it
doesn't do anything. It's like, would
you rather play whenever you cast an
uncreation spell, you gain one life? You
wouldn't, right? And this doesn't seem
to work in our deck. Again, Arch
Commander, we're not doing Voltron.
We're not attacking for much. And
this would work in a more offensive
deck, in a Voltrony deck, or even this
as the commander, right? You can play
Voltron, you can kill people. But in
this deck, even though it's a sweet
dragon, I don't think there's enough
payoff for what we want to do. So, I'll
put that in the maybe pile.
Observed stasis enchant uh flash enchant
creature and opponent controls. When
this aura enters, remove enchanted
creature from combat. Then draw a card
for each tapped creature is controller
controls. Enchanted creature loses all
abilities and can't attack or block.
I don't like this too much for two
reasons. Reason number one is because it
is an enchantment. I know our commander
says none creature, but most of the
other cards that can work in this deck
will say instance or sorceries. Yeah,
not many cards in magic or in this color
say none creature spells. And also at
the same time, this card has two
abilities. It's a draw ability and also
it's a kind of a maze of if ability to
remove an attacker. But you don't want
these two abilities on the same card.
And what I mean by that is sometimes an
opponent attacks with a few small
creatures. That's the perfect
opportunity to draw, but then you're
wasting the maze of vith ability and
sometimes an opponent is attacking you
with one large creature. You want to use
it, but then you're just drawing one
card. So I think you're much better off
with a just a removal spell. Like in
blue, we don't need to play suboptimal
removal and suboptimal draw in blue
white. Yeah. So I will put this in
maybe. I It's a cool card, but
not in this deck.
Eye of Nidth Hog.
Enchanted creature is a black dragon
with base power toughness 42. Has flying
and death touch and is golded. When Eye
of Nit is put into graveyard from the
battlefield, return it to its owner's
hand. Again, it's an enchantment. I
don't like it, but this ability is much
better that you can gold their big
thing. And
yeah, it's reusable, so you can continue
to trigger trigger to continue to do
damage.
So, it's like you always have something
to cast.
Okay, this one again, it's not my
favorite card. I might cut it later, but
for now, again, I feel like I'm cutting
I'll be cutting like half of this deck.
And again, I want to I want to clarify.
I'm I am making suggestions based on
power and function. And but commander is
not just about that. You can play
whatever you want. If you like these
cards, play them. Your deck won't be
terrible, but I'm just trying to
optimize and see what we can do to make
this deck as good as possible. So, this
I'll keep for now.
Next up, Fandaniel. Faniel. Teleopay.
I I It's the first time where a card I
can't read a single word on this card,
but Faniel. Okay. Faniel, I think, is
the closest word I got. So, Faniel, uh,
whenever you cast an instrument or
sorcery, Surveil one,
again, minimal payoff. It's better than
plus one puzzle unblockable, but it's
still minimal. At the beginning of your
end step, each opponent may sacrifice a
non-token creature of their choice. Each
opponent who doesn't lose his two life
for each instant and sorcery card in
your graveyard. This can do a decent
amount of damage, but it really depends
on our opponent. And see, this one cares
about instant sorceries. That makes
sense. And then our deck is filled with
equipments and aurus.
Uh but if we modify this deck to be more
instant sorcery based, I can see this
card I can see this card being okay.
Yeah. So I'll cue this in for now.
Again, it's not the best card, but it's
synergistic and it's I think it's
passable.
Reaper Scythe, another equipment. At the
beginning of your end start, put a soul
counter on this for each player who's
lost life this turn. So usually it would
be three because of our commander and
equipped creature gets plus one plus one
for each soul counter on this equipment
and it's an assassin. So we're getting
plus three and then the turn well the
first turn we get nothing. The second
turn is plus three and then the turn
after we get the equipment that gives
plus six. There is synergy
but it depends too much on our commander
being on the board. We're not really an
aggressive beatd down deck from what I
can see. And yeah, I don't think this
does enough.
I don't know.
Let's deck transpose. Draw a card then
discard card. You don't you have no idea
how happy I am to see instant to see an
instant or sorcery. Like this is what it
should be, right? So we can draw this
card and then we get a wizard that pings
people and then rebound. Yeah. See, this
is the kind of card we want. Arbert,
warrior of darkness. Whenever you cast a
white spell, put a plus one plus one
counter on each legendary. They gain
vigilance. Whenever you cast a black
spell, put a plus one counter on each
legendary. They gain they get menace.
Are we
Is this an aggro deck? And I'm just
misunderstanding everything.
I mean, our commander works okay with
aggro, right? Our commander is okay with
but it's just so much better with
spellinger. If we're playing aggro,
what's the point of this non creature
spell phrase?
Yeah, we are. I'm still on the spell
slinger hill, but we'll see. We'll see.
I'm open to to changing my mind, but for
now, this is not not for this deck. EMTT
Selch. The third seat spells you cast
from your graveyard cost two less to
cast. Whenever one or more opponents
lose life, you may cast target instant
or sorcery from your graveyard. If that
spell will be put into your graveyard,
exile it instead. Do it once each turn.
Yeah, see that's got great synergy with
our commander because we cast a spell
and our opponents lose life and then we
can cast that same spell again from the
graveyard, right? Yes. For two less and
then we draw a card. So yeah, this see
this is the kind of card we're looking
for. It's excellent.
Estan varino.
Whenever you cast non creature spell,
put a plus one counter on Estan against
flying until the I swear. Okay, I'll
finish reading. But at the beginning of
your second main phase, you draw X cards
and lose X life where X is the number of
opponents who were dealt damage by Eston
or a dragon this turn. So, we are a
dragon deck. Now,
again, like I was saying in the other
video, they have to do top down design
for this set. So, a lot of the legendary
creatures, they can't really be, you
know, perfect fit for the commander. And
also this is I I believe it's one Final
Fantasy game per deck. I don't remember
what this what game this deck is, but
there are lots of creatures you have to
represent in a spell in your deck. So,
it's definitely difficult to build. But
knowing that restriction, it's easier
for us to accept that a lot of the cards
here don't work. Again, it's like
they're trying to trick us into
thinking, oh, this is a noncreature
spell card, but it's not. It's just it's
a it's like an aggro card that is a
dragon payoff, but it's an elf warrior.
Yeah. So, this is not not going to work
with our deck.
Hild de Brand Hilda Brand Manders Veil
Manderville.
It's got adventure. Create a black
zombie token. And once he comes out, he
comes back from the adventure, you get
creature tokens you control, get plus
one plus one. When Hilderbrand
Mandavville dies, you may cast it from
your graveyard as an adventure until the
end of your next turn.
Uh,
it's not great. I mean, it's kind of a
creature token payoff. Right now, we
have four token cards,
token making cards. If we see another
five or six, we can be like, "Okay, this
is a Spellinger token stack, which has
some synergy, unlike the Spellinger
equipments or enchantment stack." So,
we're going to put this in maybe, but he
might come back. Might have a use.
Krill Baldesen
lifelink. Whenever you cast an
uncreature spell, you may return target
creature card with mana value equal to
that spell's mana value from your
graveyard to your hand. do this only
once each turn.
Uh, it sounds good, but again, we are
not a creatures deck. We're cutting a
lot of creatures. So, and we have to
have the exact same mana value. It can't
be It's not that mana value or lower.
So, what's the chance of
Yeah, I don't think this will be doing
enough in our deck.
Yeah, I'll leave this aside for now. for
now. If it in the end it turns out that
all of our spells are like two, three,
four mana and all of our creatures are
two, three, four, then sure. Especially
if we have a lot of four mana spells,
maybe we can use this to return our
commander, but the use seems pretty
limited.
So maybe next up, lice hex.
Non-creature spells cost one less to
cast prowess. As long as you've cast two
or more non-creature spells this turn,
lice hex has double strike.
again this trap. And why would we want a
a big double strike creature in a
spellinger deck? We're killing our
opponents with our commander. We don't
need a 44 double strike. But then
reducing the cost of non-creature spells
is fine. It's fine. But when it comes to
cost reduction, we have way better
tools. Like we have enchantments and
artifacts that are four mana, right?
That can trigger our commander. Why
would we want a creature that does it?
It's a decent blocker, but I don't think
Yeah, I don't think that we might be
cutting 20 cards here. Maybe more than
20 cards.
I hope not. Whenever you cast creature
spell, papo total deals one damage to
each opponent and you gain one life.
Again, what was I saying earlier? This
is I This is not the worst one. It's
okay, but it's still not a great payoff.
sacrifice papal limo to limo. Each
opponent who lost life this turn
sacrifices a creature with the greatest
power among creatures you control. So,
it's a removal. See, it seems good. It
seems good, but is this better than just
casting a three mana spell that what's
it called? I forgot the name, but I'll
put the card on the on the uh video.
Each opponent sacrifices a creature or
sacrifices half their creatures.
Yeah, you just play a spell and trigger
your commander rather than playing a
creature that Yeah. Again, they're
trying really hard to make these
creatures fit. I understand, but it
doesn't really work.
Uringer Augur route. Whenever you play a
land from exile or cast a spell from
exile, you gain two life. You can tap to
exile the top card of your library and
then you can tap to play it.
And spells you play this way cost two
less to cast. So, it's basically tap to
draw, but it takes two turns. Then you
get the payoff of it costing two less
and you can gain two life. Usually for
cards like this, you the buildaround
class is the first one. And then the the
text after is like he can trigger
himself if you have no other cards that
trigger it, but it's really inefficient.
But none of this looks good. Like we're
not playing things for exile.
And even if we are, gain two life is not
a not a good payoff. And you have to tap
twice to get one card in a blue deck.
No, this is It just doesn't do enough.
And there's no synergy with our
commander. Archaers Map.
This is Yeah, now we're on to reprints.
This is a decent ram spot. It's a pretty
good ramp spot, I say. And even though
it's not an instant or sorcery, but it
triggers our commander, so I think it's
fine. It's reasonable.
Authority of the consoles. This is a
very annoying card. It gains us life,
but it doesn't do anything other than
that. Like your opponents are slightly
annoyed. They might attack you more, but
it doesn't work with anything we're
doing at the moment. It doesn't even
work with our creatures entering. Say if
we're going for tokens. So, it's a good
card. It's a It's a decent card, but not
for this deck. Cleansing Nova, an
excellent board wipe to play. Yeah, very
flexible creatures or artifacts and
enchantments. We definitely need need
lots of board wipes in this deck. Final
judgment, not the best board wipe. I
mean, especially considering how far is
a theme, but I think it's serviceable.
It's never bad to exile.
I mean, we have way better options now
in black and white, but again, this not
a bad card, so we'll keep it in for now.
Yeah. See, this is the kind of payoff
that is that is good enough, right?
Whenever you cast a copy in instrument
or sorcery, draw a card. Yeah. Not plus
one plus not deal one damage draw a
card. This is the kind of payoff we
want.
Solid dig through time. Eight mana
spell.
Yeah, beautiful. What's nice is that our
legendary creatures care about mana
value, not the cost paid or the mana
paid, which is very abusable. And they
threw time is one of the best cards for
that. Right of replication. Yeah, for
spelling decks, we need win conditions
and this is a decent way to win the
game. Pick the best creature on the
board. Get five copies of it late game.
Can definitely finish a mid-powered
table.
Sublime Epiphany.
This is Oh, yeah. This is one of the
best spelling cards. It's made for
commander. Six mana. Do everything.
Yeah, this is sweet. See, the reprints
are quality, but what the new cars, you
can see they are, their hands are tied
when they made the new cards. Torrential
Gearhulk. Beautiful. Excellent card. Cru
crux of fate. Less beautiful. We are not
a dragon stack. Again, if we flip five,
six dragons for for the next half. Okay,
I will stand corrected, but we are not a
dragon stack. And
no, we'll play better board wipes.
Lethal scheme. Destroy target creature
or planes walker. Each creature convoke.
Oh, it's got convoke. Okay,
I guess convoke is nice cuz we we can
make some tokens. Again, not the best
removal, but serviceable and I can see
it being okay in this deck. Next up,
Murderous Rider. Also an okay removal.
I'm not sure why they feel the need to
attack on a creature. They feel the need
to play adventure
because this the creature side doesn't
even trigger our commander. Doesn't even
trigger the two spells a turn. So,
we're just playing this for the removal,
which is a decent removal. Like, I'll
keep it in, but doesn't make too much
sense. Billful tricks also doesn't make
sense, but it's just never bad to have
two mana, enter draw a card, and it will
block for you cuz usually when you're
spelling your deck, your opponents are
pressuring you and billful tricks will
block will basically keep all the large
creatures away unless they want to
trade. So, this is Yeah, you're never
sad to see this card.
Solid. Vindicate,
excellent removal, but sorcery speed is
a strike. We are in the best removal
colors, I'd say. So, no, this is not
good enough. For example, see, void rent
is a solid removal. Destroy pretty much
anything and can't be countered. Yeah,
this is what we're looking for in
removals.
Coveted jewel.
What? Why are we playing this?
Like we're not amazing at defending
ourselves.
Yeah, I don't like we don't need the
card draw and we have better mana rocks,
right? We're in blue. We have better
ways to draw cards than something this
risky. So, we're fine. Yeah, we're not
playing this
tome of Legends.
Again, we are in blue. We don't need to
draw cards by sending our two four
commander into the red zone. Yeah, just
to pay one and draw two. Draw one. Yeah.
Again, we're in blue. We don't need to
play these cards.
Okay, let's skip the lands for now. Move
on to non lands.
White oright four mana.
When it enters, exile something. I don't
think this does enough. It's a temporary
removal
on a mana rock, but four mana mana rock.
I I don't think this is good enough.
Yeah, we have way better rocks to play.
Sages.
Another equipment. Two mana equipment.
Excellent synergy.
That was sarcasm, by the way. Don't
don't listen to that. Equip creature
gives plus one plus O has whenever this
creature attacks, untap target attacking
creature. We are. Yeah, we're attacking
our vigilance commander, right?
So, why why are we doing equipments?
Yeah, right now I think I feel confident
enough to dump all these Well, not this
one, but all of the equipments into the
cut pile. And let's see how far how many
cuts we have right now. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 12 13 14 15 16 17
20 cuts already.
Once again, I want to say if you like
the characters, if you like the deck,
keep it together by all means. No
problems. But this deck needs a major
overhaul to try to come even close to uh
to the potential of this of this
commander. This is a really powerful
commander and yeah, we want to make
build the d deck around this theme.
So that's what we're going to try to do.
Yeah, I think a rebuild is in line.
Circle of Power. Draw two, lose two,
create a wizard. Yeah, this is solid.
Cut a deal. Each opponent draws a card,
then you draw a card. For each opponent
who draw a card this way, we are in blue
black. There's literally a black card
that says each opponent discard a card.
You draw a card for each card discarded
this way. I'll put it on the screen. Why
are we We just straight up swap this for
that, right?
Lingering souls.
I get it. It triggers our opponent our
commander twice, but also triggers our
opponent twice, but it doesn't do
enough. Doesn't do enough, I don't
think. Swords to polishers, excellent
removal. Although in this deck, maybe I
will I prefer high mana cost removals,
but swords is never bad, I guess. So,
it's fine. It's also sweet art.
Hypnotic sprite.
Instant adventure counter target spell
with mana value and then it's a two
mana. Why are we playing adventure
cards?
Why? There's no reason. We also have
what? Cast from exile sub team. We have
five sub team themes teams in this deck.
No, we're not playing this counter
spell. There are way better counter
spells to play into the story. Seven
mana. This spell costs three less if an
opponent has seven or more cards in the
graveyard.
This usually is fine in the late game.
In the mid game, your opponents usually
have seven cards on the graveyard, even
if we're not actively milling them. So,
I think this is fine.
There are a better draw spells again.
But I think this is serviceable and it's
kind it's kind of synergistic with our
big spell theme. Although, we only have
one card that kind of triggers off big
spells
that cares about the mana value, I
think. But it's a fine card. Yeah,
propaganda.
We again are not great at defending
ourselves. Our two for vigilance
commander. We can't hold the fort by
oursel. So propaganda is a great card to
play. People usually don't want to pay
the two especially if they're going
white.
Bastion of remembrance.
Okay. So this is a tokens card. We'll
put that in the tokens pile. Did we also
just cut a tokens card? We might make a
little pile for tokens. Yeah, this is a
tokens card. No, it's not a good one.
But and I guess all these equipments
kind of make one token, but no, it's not
that's not how it works. Exangun,
excellent big spell for draining our
opponents. Uh it's mostly useful for
gaining life, but it can finish games in
the end. And yeah, just a really solid
spell,
difficult to cut. Snuff out.
I mean, there are better removals, but
our commander kind of pays for this life
life payment. And at the same time,
it's nice to be able to cast three
spells because we want two spells a
turn. So, I can see why this is in the
deck. It's not great. Later, we might
cut it, but for now can stay. Oh, see,
there it is. Yeah, I was talking about
this card. I guess there's no need to
put put it on the on the on the video
anymore. Yeah, each other player
discards a card. You draw a card for
each card. this card this way. In blue
and black, you have so many excellent
draw spells. Yeah, we're not going to
play a white draw spell. So, aside from
mind, go in. Definitely. Okay, on to
ramp. Arcane signate. Relic of legends.
Sure. Soaring. Okay. Talisman. Talisman.
Seems good. Thought vessel to keep our
hand. Okay. And then we were on to
lands. Not much to say about lands, I
think. Anything special here?
Okay. Land destruction.
Not sure we need evolving wells in this
kind of deck. Just play a basic. It's
better probably. Path of ancestry.
This is in every deck. Not sure why. I
guess we're all mostly What are we cats
in this deck? Not sure. Temple of the
false god. Yeah, they have the same
lands in every deck. I'm not sure about
the land choice. They could have put
more a little more thought and put in
more specific lands.
But again, for lens, the primary use is
manifixing. And the mana fixing in these
decks are decent. I think they're solid.
There isn't a dire need to upgrade the
land base. Scavenger grounds. Great.
Yeah. So, we are fine. All right. Let's
take a quick look at the basics. I think
it's the same ones. Yeah, they're cool.
Hero token. Hero token. Colorless hero.
Hero wizard. Bird.
Cool. Okay, let's open our pack and then
we will Whoops. We'll sort the deck.
Add card Esperus to Magisite and
Alphanod Leveler.
Cool. Cool. All right, we'll be back.
All right, here we have the cards
separated. And uh here are the cards we
ended up cutting. Unfortunately, we have
to cut 25 cards. Some of the token
stuff, some of the equipments, and just
cards that are not impactful enough. And
I have no idea some cards why why
they're in the deck. Yeah. So, a pretty
big overhaul.
And here are the pile. Here's the pile
that's left. And lands. We've got 37 of
these. It's fine. 37 lands.
These are untouched. And next up is kind
of the core of the deck. Spell slingers.
Payoffs. Yeah, the cards that are
decent.
We've got a few here. And next up,
draw spells. One, two, three, four,
five, six. We ended up keeping six cross
spells. We will need a lot more just
because in a control deck, you're
constantly exchanging resources and you
will have spare mana, right? There there
will be times where you don't have to
use your mana. And our goal is to turn
any spare mana into a instant speed
draw.
And spot removals, I guess, answers.
Here we have yeah, five spot removals
along with this one, which is like a
spot removal and a counter spell. It's
excellent. And then two board wipes.
We'll need more spot removals just
because we don't really build a board
super well. So, we need to keep things
down. And at the same time, board wipes
we need more of. Two is not enough.
Ramp. One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight. Eight pieces. We're not
adding ramp per se, but we're adding
land tax effects. You will see. Uh,
yeah.
Then finishers got right of replication,
got King Mog, and Exanguinate. Honestly,
this is pretty weak. We need to add some
finishers to this deck. We can't just
depend on our commander to close out the
game. It's too slow. And once you're in
control, everyone will be gunning for
you. And no matter how good your deck
is, it will be difficult to do a
archeneemy. So, we'll put in some
finishers. And just here's some generic
utility. All right, let's take a look
first, I guess, at the quoteunquote ramp
spells. I put in land tax and weather
wfairer. Now, these two are, I'd say,
kind of staples in decks that are white
and not green, just because hitting your
land drops is more important than ramp.
Yeah, the mana value of basically
hitting a land drop is somewhere between
two to three mana. It's worth that much.
So, if you can just get lands with
these, never miss a land drop, then it's
way better than any ramp spell can
possibly do. So, we're adding these to
the light ramp pile. And next up, card
draw. Just some of the best instant
speed card draw spells. We've got Oh,
this is not card draw. But here, Mystic
Confluence is counter spell and a card
draw, but I put it in the card draw
category because I think most of the
time you will be drawing. Don't counter
something just for the sake of it. Draw
three. You know, when there's something
worth countering, you can target it, but
usually I wouldn't counter something
unless I have to. Una's Grace is kind of
interesting because uh it's not
efficient. It's really inefficient, but
you can keep casting it from your
graveyard, especially with some of the
cost reducers. You can keep doing it and
trigger your commander over and over and
over. So, this is quite a special card
that works in this deck. Uh, right here.
Oops. This goes here. And pull from
tomorrow. Just a classic. Usually, you
can fire it off for a fair bit in the
mid game. This will refill your hand.
Treasure cous. Cuz we're not doing too
much with our graveyard. So, we have we
have uh what's it called? The other
exile. Oh, slipping my mind. I'll find
it. We have dick through time. Yes. And
treasure cruise. That's it.
There should be plenty of cards for us
to delve. So, usually just one mana draw
three. Two mana draw three. Commander
Insight. Now, this is three blue for the
base cost, but the X will usually be
plus one just because you've cast your
commander once. And late game, it can be
a lot more. And lastly, Sphinx is
revelation. Life game is important when
you can do life and card draw. Why not?
You can see I have a lot of these uh
late game draw spells to make sure that
we are not all. We're never alast
unwind. This is the kind of counter
spell that fits this deck, I believe,
because it doesn't really cost mana,
right? You can just use it, trigger your
commander, and then untap to prepare for
the next spell. Yeah, you can unwind,
untap everything, and then cast a
removal. And now you're getting an extra
card draw from our commander.
And uh here are the answers. And next we
have excise the imperfect. This card is
not seeing a lot of play. Maybe because
of the double white mana isn't really an
issue here I believe especially white
mana but uh just being able to exile
pretty much anything and what you give
them is minimal. Yeah. So this is a
really versatile removal that triggers
our commander and generous gift. similar
uh I think it's arguably I mean can
destroy lands so I I'd say but it
doesn't excel so it's a lot on par with
excise they're both really good and
trigger arch matter stroke of midnight a
little worse but still good enough and
lastly anguish making so yeah we're
trying to putting three mana ones that
are versatile so that we not only get to
remove something anything we need to and
also get a commander trigger
next for board wipes first one is
etherites.
Yeah, this is one of the better instant
speed kind of board wipes where you
don't have to because board wipes are
proactive and that's not ideal because
you don't know who your opponents are
attacking. But for this, you can wait
till you're sure you know they're
attacking you, then you fire it off and
that's super effective. And alongside
this, there's also route for a similar
board wipe. Where's my Oh, it's fine. Uh
alongside etheriz route is also an
excellent instant speed option. This in
a pinch you can cast it for five mana
but ideally you hold up seven mana and
wait for your opponents to act first.
See what they do then decide if you need
to wipe because these word wipes they
kill your commander. So ideally but but
there will be worse that there will be
boards that need to be wiped. So this is
for when that happens. Farewell the best
word wipe clears everything. When your
opponents are just gumming up the board,
it's not efficient for us to take down
their permanence one by one. Just clear
everything. Graveyard, artifacts,
creatures. Yeah, not much to say about
farewell. Tragic arrogance. I like
because we can keep our commander, but
at the same time, if your opponents have
multiple permanence of the same type,
they're keeping the worst. So, usually
this is a clean wipe for your opponents.
Yeah, they get one permanent, but but
it's not much. It's not going to be
much. And next up, destroy the dead. I
like this one because it's kind of like
blasphemous act where the cost is
usually reduced to double white. Yeah,
usually when a board is worth wiping,
it's going to cost double white. So that
you can cast this and then be the first
to rebuild.
Okay, once we've got all the answers,
there's a lot of answers, I know, but
that's kind of how this deck usually
plays. We've got some of the
miscellaneous utility good stuff and
finishers. Now, Primal Amulet is is the
cost reducer I I choose because it's
four mana. It is none creature and uh
it's got a pretty nice upside where you
can flip it and it turns into a land
that can copy spells. Yeah. So, late
game, this can win you the game when you
when you combine it with some of the
other win conditions.
This goes here. Actually, utility goes
here. And font of magic. Yeah, this can
reduce our spells by a fair bit. one,
two, sometimes three. Hopefully not more
than that because then we probably won't
be casting our commander. We won't be
able to access our commander again. But
yeah, this is one of the better cost
reducers.
Next up, some of the win conditions.
Tolerance Sky Summoner. This is what a
spell slinger payoff should look like,
right? Just basic four mana. Every spell
gets you a two two flying. Excellent for
defense, excellent for offense. Not much
to say. So, finishers and also Shard
Typhoon is this is a bit difficult to
see, but I'll put a clearer version on
the on the video and
yeah, it's a excellent payoff. This also
cares about mana value rather than the
mana you spent. So, all the big spells
you cheat are excellent with this. Next
up, Ink Shield featuring Sheldon Meery.
is one of the perfect defense cards that
can turn into a win condition. Yeah, if
your opponent wants to alpha strike you
with a greater hoof, you know, the
second best play would be to to etherize
them
with etherize, but the best play is in
shield where you fog protect yourself
and the back swing will be lethal for
everyone.
And debt to the death list. If you're
playing Zangunate, you got to play debt.
This is just better in late game. This
can drain everyone for 10 15 uh life.
And even if it doesn't kill people, this
will drag you back into the game. You
are back in the driver's seat. And
lastly, a few cards that are like cheat
codes with our commander. First of all,
curiosity.
Yeah. When you enchant this onto where's
our commander? Onto our commander. Every
three CMC or higher spell you cast
becomes draw how many? Draw three. Yeah,
it comes draw three, which is ridiculous
value. With this on your commander, you
are protecting this combination at all
costs and you this will win you the
game. And the last card is one that I
don't have right now, but it's called
Helm of the Gast Lord. I believe it's a
similar effect to Curiosity. I'll put it
on the screen and it says whenever
whenever
the enchanted creature deals damage to
an opponent, that opponent discards a
card and you draw a card. Yeah. And with
this with Yota is just a ridiculous. I
believe that card shot up in price since
the spoiler of Yota, but it's not too
too expensive right now, so it's fairly
reasonable. And this is the deck we
have. It's a fairly strong control deck.
And I I have to admit, I did put in a
lot of control pieces. And as you play
with your group, if this is turning out
to be too oppressive, you can absolutely
switch out some of the answers for cards
you like. But for now, I think this is a
good base to start with so that and then
you can adjust, you can uh yeah, you can
change the cards. You can put in some
pet cards based on the power level you
want to uh you want to achieve. But I
think this will have a pretty good
chance against the other precons as is.
Yeah, that's all for this deck. Next up,
we have Cloud the Limit Break deck. So,
please like and subscribe and let me
know if you enjoy this kind of content.
Should I make more or should I go back
to making kind of video essay videos?
All right, see you.